is this mind at large akin to what in
other religions
they call god and can you pray to it
does it intervene
i don't think um we have good reasons to
think of
the mind underlying the rest of nature
in other words the mind that's not my
mind
your mind the mind of my cat the mind
that is not in any living being in other
words the non-dissociated segments of
of universal mind i think we do not have
good reasons to think of this
non-dissociated segment which i
call mind at large we don't have good
reasons to think of it
as self-reflective
as capable of metacognition of capable
of having the thought
oh i am having this thought i think it's
more akin to my cat it has experiences
but it doesn't think of its experiences
as such it's not self-reflective it's
not metacognitive
so from that perspective i don't think
the unfolding of nature is the result of
a premeditated plan
drawn in the very beginning of time and
now carefully unfolding under
supervision
i don't think that's what's happening i
am a naturalist i think nature is
unfolding the way it is because it is
what it is
it can't be any different i think
interpreting it as
mental which i think is what's actually
going on
only informs us that this unfolding is
instinctive
rather than premeditated so i wouldn't
pray to it as if it were
a thinking human being in the sky
with a plan and making explicit and
thought through decisions about the fate
of every human being
i think i i think that's that's not how
stuff is happening that's not what's
going on i think it's unfolding
via its natural archetypes its preferred
ways of unfolding that set
setting an intention i think
can influence the world
for the exact same reasons that moving
your arms can influence the world
our mental activity leaves a footprint
in the world
by having being here our environment
is what it is or wouldn't have been if
we were not here
i mean to speak in physical terms in in
other words in in the language of
representations and images
we occupy a volume in space if i were to
suddenly disappear
air would rush into that volume of space
and probably create a sonic boom i don't
i don't know
it would make a thundering noise because
that's exactly what thunder is it's air
filling in
the vacuum of overheated air left by
lightning
so our very presence in the world
changes
the world and i think this is very
obvious when it comes to our physical
influence in the world by
building a house with our hands by
moving around
but i think the same type of influence
is plausible when it comes to the
deepest layers of our mind which may not
be as dissociated as our ego is
in other words it may have more commerce
with the mentation around us
so if you set a deep intention through
prayer
i do think it is plausible that you may
get an effect
but not for the reasons you may think
you may get an effect
um so it works as if but the mechanism
is
exactly yeah